- What's up Believe Nation,
I want to give away some
free stuff every single day
to you guys while quantities last,
and I'm excited to announce what
we're going to be giving away.
So, the reason why I'm doing this,
I made a video not too long ago,
YouTube really values views and engagement
in the first 24 hours,
especially if you got new videos up.
It's called view velocity.
- Within the first 48 hours,
YouTube really makes a determination
as to whether this video is
going to be served very broadly
or whether it's going
to just kind of go back
to the video corpus where it'll receive
very few views over its lifetime.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so if I
want to sort of play the system
what should I do?
- You should focus on getting views
very early in a video's lifespan,
this means featuring the video
across your social media,
sending it out on an email
blast as soon as possible,
the sort of thing that can drive
a lot of view velocity very early.
- So, the more you get views on a video
soon after it comes out
to your subscribers,
the more likely YouTube...
He was making noises with the dog toy.
The more likely YouTube
is going to promote
those videos across their network.
And so I wanted to figure
out a way to get you guys
to watch more of the videos,
but also reward you for
doing so and being engaged,
and more importantly,
watching the videos quickly,
and not waiting a week or month
because that negatively impacts
my videos and my channel.
You want to see Teemo?
Want to say hi to Teemo?
Come say hi, Teemo.
This is Teemo.
He's getting his adult teeth in.
You excited to be on camera, mister?
You excited to be on camera?
This is his new toy that Nina bought.
(toy squeaking)
So if you hear that, that's
where it's coming from.
See, look how excited he gets.
(toy squeaking)
You want that, huh?
Okay, good boy.
Alright, so,
that's what I'm trying to do.
In the contest, here's
what I'm going to be doing.
We're going to be giving away
two things every single day.
It's a lot to maintain, but
I'm excited to test it out.
The first thing is I'm going to give away
some of my Entrepreneur
Heroes Trading Cards.
You will either get one of these
special edition Steve Jobs, Steve Wozniak,
with numbers on it, numbered edition.
Or you'll get individual
cards from the series.
We got Steve Jobs and A.P. Giannini
and all these famous entrepreneurs.
We've worked with Tim
Ferriss and Gary Vaynerchuk
and a whole bunch of
different people on this.
And I'll also be giving away
a session with Lily Ma
who is a coach on my team
and is leading One Word workshops for me.
She normally charges $100 an
hour for her coaching sessions
and she's going to be
giving away sessions daily
for you guys as well.
So here are the rules,
here's how you can
qualify and enter and win.
This is what's up.
First of all we're going to be looking at,
every single day, in the morning,
the past three videos.
It's going to be the
most recent Entspresso,
in the morning, whatever
the morning slot is,
the evening slot and the noon slot.
We usually produce videos in
the morning, noon and evening.
So it's going to be that morning video,
the one from last night
and the one from noon the day before.
Those are the videos we're
going to be checking out,
every single morning.
Whoever has the comment
that has the most likes
is going to win the cards.
A single card, one of
the special edition cards
or a pack of cards.
Every single day,
so we're going to be looking
at whoever has the most
likes on a comment.
So it's hopefully encouraging people
to leave comments that
get liked as well, right?
To leave engaging comments.
I didn't want to do
something where you're just
putting something stupid in
and it counts as a comment,
I wanted to put something
that adds value to the communities,
so we're not just creating
a contest to game a system,
but you're creating something
that actually adds value to
Believe Nation, you guys.
So hopefully it encourages you
to leave good comments that people enjoy,
and people want to read and
engage with and click the like.
So that's how we're going
to track it for the cards,
and you also have to put your BTA number,
your hashtag BTA number.
If you don't know what #BTA is,
check the link in the
description, you can go find out.
For Lily's coaching session,
what we're going to do
is a more subjective one.
We're going to pick the comment of the day
that has the most
Believe embodiment to it.
So it's not necessarily
the most popular one,
the one that has the most thumbs up,
but the one that just embodies
the Believe spirit the most.
Lily's going to be picking it,
so she's going to be identifying which one
she believes embodies Believe the most.
And that winner will be contacted
and you get a free session with Lily,
and I hope you enjoy
'cause it's pretty
interesting and life-changing
to be able to go through
a process with her.
So,
for you guys,
you see a video come out,
watch it within 24 hours or sooner.
Leave a good-quality
Believe-worthy comment on it.
Feel good, feel proud that
you absorbed knowledge.
You shared with Believe Nation community.
And you have a chance
to win some cool prizes.
So that's what I'm
thinking for now at least,
looking forward to starting the contest
and it launches officially right now.
Good luck guys.
And PS, we're going to notify the winners
in the comments section,
so underneath your comment,
if it was a winning comment
underneath there's going to be
a comment from my team that says
"Congratulations, you won one
of the prizes of the day."
From there what you want to do
is just email a screenshot of your comment
to free@evancarmichael.com,
and we may need to get your address
if we're sending you the cards,
or we'll get more information
so you can get connected with Lily
so you can get your prizes.
So pay attention to the comments
because you want to make sure
you get your notification.
Good luck.